congratulations in this film first time
director knocked it out of the park who
gave you some great advice and directing
a lot of the directors that I work with
a lot of friends and then I I kept
thinking back to all these incredible
people that I've worked with and and the
feeling of certain sets that I was on
you also directed your son Jack in the
film now how would you compare directing
Jack as an actor to directing him as a
mom in real life growing up he's always
been such a creative kid so a certain
point actually when we were shooting we
were shooting on a train and I thought
it's really no different than you know
my last 20 years with Jack Wade Jack
tonight I know he isn't here cos he's
shooting with Steven Soderbergh how
proud are you I mean what an incredible
film I just I can't take I get too happy
talking about him and now that he's 24 I
was on a plane actually recently and one
of the when the stewardesses said oh we
had just your son I'm the plane and he
was such a polite guy and what a charmer
and he's so great in the movie so lovely
he's got a small part and he's great
came from Scorsese's set to myself also
in Ithaca makes close pal and frequent
co-star Tom Hanks he's just such a
mensch he's just such a lovely guy and
he didn't like this much of our little
movie but he made everybody smile when
he was there so and you know we couldn't
talk to Meg Ryan without asking her this
question when was the last time you were
asked to recreate the infamous from Hera
Harry Met Sally seemed like this morning
really
maybe and it's almost every time I go
out to eat Oh
I'll have what she's having